when you have something like on seven
Psalms when you which I love that hook
that thing that you do on it that
[Music]
this sort of sort of is influenced by
English folk the English folk scene of
the 60s which is when I was living there
you know 64 65. when you come up with a
a riff like that with seven songs are
you in the house all day just playing
that over and over and over again until
that's your that's your life it came in
a dream it wasn't the first time that
I've ever dreamed something about music
but this was such a strong dream that I
woke up and wrote down seven Psalms
January 15
2019. I was listening to seven Psalms
and I'm listening to it and I'm
responding to it and then you get to
that lyric it's on uh love is like a
braid
I lived a life of pleasant Sorrows until
the real deal came I went whoa now
that's something I can it blew my mind
what was the real deal for you in other
words you're describing Sorrows that you
think when you were a kid were really
bad oh it's in kind of an Indulgence
it's kind of when you look back on it
kind of defines you and it's almost
sweet yeah but then something major
happens in your life where you lose
somebody or you lose something and I
mean what were you thinking about
specifically there I think what I was
thinking of there because it was
happening at about the same time was the
loss of my hearing and and the left ear
um thinking that that
loss
for me I mean of course I lost my
parents too but uh but that was in the
you know in the the way of nature right
uh a hearing came out of nowhere like
you didn't Tusk it wasn't even gradual
right it was gradual and then uh I had a
procedure that I was supposed to improve
it and in fact it took all the hearing
away